you can keep spending without and bring  down inflation so here's what I think  I think that we're not going to be able  to bring an interest rate to a high  enough level to give a good real return  to Holders of credit  and without  causing a contraction in economic  activity worse than what we're  experiencing right you had an eight  percent eight percent inflation rate  look at what people get and we're  talking now about a three percent  interest rate and people think that  that's good right so you're going to  lose money and lose buying power I think  the inflation will come down a bit but  it's going to be very high and money is  going to get a lot tighter tighter so  you're going to have a stagflation